hello guys my name is Archana and
welcome to the ninth episode of the
serialization series so last time we
talked about fields and we implemented
this field class which more or less just
writes out a bunch of data ok and we had
all these um we had these subclasses of
field that basically it just made our
lives easier they didn't really do
anything like there's no reason that
should really be a subclass I thought
from the fact that it just kind of set
some some default properties like you
could easily just implement this as a
static kind of class like as in as if
you could do something like public
static field create the until just int
and then you could take in that same
name right string name wasn't in value
and then you could just kind of copy and
paste this copy of aces over here and
you'd get the same result right this
would just do exactly the same thing
well you know if I kind of actually
properly do this and it would look
something like this and it would do the
same thing alright it's up to you what
you want to do there's no penalty in
creating it as like as a subclass I
think it just looks a bit cleaner I get
it
API wise it doesn't even matter like it
will kind of still look the same I think
like that will yeah I mean it'll it's up
to you what you want to do right it
actually might make more sense I think I
might just do it this way right now I'm
making this decision as I go along by
the way because it means that I don't
have to create a thousand Colossus and
that will take time and they all have to
be in one file which is very annoying so
let's do that actually let's just do it
create int now I'm just gonna call it
like that all right so we've got integer
I mean we might as well go through this
now and quickly implement all the other
ones
I'll put these at the very bottom so
we've got integer will do byte what
these in order of size I guess so byte
and we'll do short and char and integer
and long
alright let's kind of go through these
and see something real quick so this
will now taking a bite more was it bite
yes yes what else name is changing I
think that's about it yeah so the other
thing we change is the types and
everything should sort itself out
properly note you can see that even if
we're running a single byte we still
kind of sorted on all right
that kind of just means that we don't
have to we don't have a special case or
anything for it it's everything is kind
of consistent which is good all right
int and long
and finally well we've got three more
don't we floats
double and belen okay so where do we
stop float double and bull in alright
done so here we have everything actually
do we even have a yes we do right right
fights bull in yeah we do fantastic okay
so we've got all that going on so now
yes we can create it just by typing like
field integer and there's our integer
let's try it out with something like a
long just have fun we'll set this to
like 10 or something one thing I do want
to quickly add that I was thinking about
while I was editing the previous episode
which is actually currently uploading
that's how much I'm just um I'm just
gonna just slap all of these out I don't
know why I chose the word slap there I'm
gonna just bang all these out and and
get this series evident honestly anyway
um so what I was thinking about last
episode was we really should have a way
to get the size of a field for obvious
reasons but if we literally just have
like a guest size I'm sure that wouldn't
be too difficult to calculate a lot
right all we know is we've basically can
just return 1 plus 2 for the name length
right
if you really want it to be precise like
I mean it depends how you want to write
this you could be really like really
kind of what's the word I'm looking for
really anal about this and just actually
you know do something like that is
that's gonna take a lot of space up and
like personally I don't care for stuff
like that especially if we're doing it
in Java and we know this
each type so I'm just gonna write it
like that feel free to write it properly
again this is yeah that's I'm not going
to um okay so we need to get the name
length so remain length and bias is just
gonna be named at length then the type
and then finally the data building all
right and that we've got we should have
everything there okay so one of the
things that I think I forgot to mention
last episode was the fact that and I'm
not sure again I'm just uploading than
the episode eight now so I don't know
what if you guys noticed this but you
might be thinking why is there no its
size given for the amount of bytes in
here well obviously because the type you
know tells us what data is in here so
the type tells us the size of this
battery for example if the type set to
end we know that there are four bytes
here they have to be okay unless it's
well they don't have to be obviously
things could happen someone could go and
modify the file and break something but
as far as we know is the reader as in
like well when we're reading this data
back we know that if we see a type of
integer we turn it read the next four
bytes okay obviously there will be
safety checks and all of that in the
reader just to make sure that it's
correct and if so if not it'll just mark
the files invalid but as far as we know
right now that's that's basically what
it is right so dark lengths basically
and we could we could do a bunch of
things here to assert it right we could
do something like asserting the fact
that data the length has to equal type
get size type or rather just type right
this has to be true
if it's not as a problem okay so that's
you know that there are certain things
we could do just to make sure that we're
kind of correct and that we don't ruin
everything I might well I might leave
these in here I might not the reason I
want to leave it in here is because the
data can get set at any time like for
example there is no like the field
constructor right now which doesn't
actually exist you know we only said
that we haven't kind of finalized the
data here so
we could be running some kind of
integrity check to make sure that
everything is correct again I'm not
gonna go ahead and set up anything like
unit testing but just let me to think
about all right if you're actually
developing this and like I would be
asserting pretty much everything okay
I'm not a hundred percent sure how these
work in Java I mean I could literally
just google it right now but but um yeah
I mean like it's always a good idea to
kind of just write assets everywhere
whether there is something that is kind
of sensitive right which is like this
stuff doesn't rely on everything being
correctly aligned like when especially
when reading this okay and then what you
can do is you can generally keep track
of like a boolean which is something
like invalid and anytime something is a
little bit off one or a little bit off
but something is definitely incorrect
you just get out of there
right and that that that's particularly
important because again since we're
dealing with kind of robot arrays a lot
could go wrong right well I mean really
the only thing could go wrong is under
flowing and overflowing and particularly
in Java overflowing so yeah you really
need to think about that okay cool
for example I have to say one of the
things that I haven't mentioned is that
every single one of these functions
right now could absolutely cause an
array index out of bounds exception yeah
I mean it's clearly gonna happen right
if you pass in a byte array here that
has a size seven well guess what this
line right here is going to end up with
an array index out of bounds exception
it's gonna happen right and I don't
really want to surround it like it's
again is a very easy to check yeah you
could definitely just say something like
if destination or you could in fact we
could we could write asserts pretty much
everywhere writing something as simple
as if destination built length is or
asserting the fact the destination that
length is greater than
points up plus what is it like eight in
this case right or type dot guess size
typed or long right if we assert
something like that
that will just kind of make sure that
we're actually not going to overflow in
fact that's probably not a bad idea I
might leave it in here for long in fact
you know since we're on a good trend of
writing quality software let's hum what
are they just int let's just yeah let's
just post everywhere but you can't get
what I'm saying right we kind of need to
make sure that we're not going to write
over protected all writing / memory that
we shouldn't be writing I'm well in this
case yeah crashing is probably the
better term okay reading is fine um so
yeah right string I mean that just
results in more right but course that's
fine this will be a boolean
let's see double
float long int cha this time I am using
get size I think it makes the code a bit
more readable as well and if we really
wanted to as well bite hmm and in this
case we could just assert it weird the
source of length all right cool
so there we go we've got some nice kind
of assertions here just to make sure
that everything is going well which is
always good to do especially because the
idea with assertions are that really
like better and existing release builds
again I actually just don't know how
that works in Java I wish I did I should
really do some research on this but the
way that assertions typically work is
there's something that you kind of keep
active in debug builds and you don't
keep them active and release builds or
distribution builds so what that means
is that when you're kind of just testing
this coding you're kind of running in
quote-unquote debug mode what happens is
these assertions are on which means that
when it enters this right bytes thing it
will it will verify it to make sure that
this boolean statement is true if it is
true it will continue on to the next
line if it is false
it will break like the compiler will or
sorry that the IDE will the debugger
that's the word only for the debugger
will break on that line and let you know
that assertion is false and then you can
be like ok I've got a stack trace and
I've got everything I need to sort out
why is this happened ok but on release
mode assertions just kind of get removed
right they go on so they don't affect
performance or anything like that
where it won't matters they only affect
performance when you're kind of
debugging which is important so that's
kind of how that whole thing works in
case you weren't really familiar with
what assert actually does again I really
should read up about it about how it
works in Java but I imagine that it's
exactly the same as it would in a and
any other language ok cool
so now the purpose of why I did that is
we can actually just do something like
field getsize now again we don't have to
kind of create that massive thing
so if we do printout along here and
something is that are in me not sure
what it is okay yeah that's right
already a bit of field okay good so
that's good
yeah so it looks like our size is
correct here again I'm not gonna go
through all these bytes but we know the
first thing that means it's the field
the next short means that's the length
with this thing so if I change this well
yeah my changes you guys believe me the
next four bytes of the actual test
characters this five I believe is the
type of data yell too long as type is
five I believe yeah here it is five and
then the next eight bytes at that actual
long so you can see it ends in a which
is ten okay cool so there we have it
that is how the field works i've just
regretted it and kind of got it to work
right so the main thing that we're kind
of gonna move on to this video is
talking about and I hope these videos
aren't getting too long I always I
always don't know what to do with videos
because like I had in my head that
people really only watch 10 to 20 minute
videos tops and that if I put out a 30
minute video people have to kind of be
like oh man I really have to make a
commitment or they book market and
return to it later I really don't don't
know what to do with videos and lengths
so like I mean I could break this video
up like it's 15 minutes right now I
could say that's it I could wrap up this
episode and I could continue what I was
going to do this episode basically next
episode but then I end up with a lot of
videos which is kind of a good thing but
also I feel that people don't watch that
because they're too many videos I don't
know what to do man this huge this whole
YouTube thing is difficult but anyway
I'm gonna just I want to just continue
this episode so and then you guys can
let me know what you think in the
comments your assistance will be greatly
appreciated but in this matter
ok cool so we're gonna move on to our
kind of next container type I guess and
that's going to be an array so arrays
are very similar to fields arrays are
literally I'm talking about literally
just flat arrays of a single data type
flat as in the fact that it's just
continuous memory all contiguous memory
wouldn't you call this array I'm gonna
take a lot of things from field I think
we can probably take the whole thing
really let's just take these things to
begin with again they are going to be
laid out as if they were field
containing type is going to be set to
array they're going to have a name the
only thing that is different is they're
going to have a type and then they're
going to have an int which is element
type I'm sorry what am i doing
count I'll just call it count so this is
element type this is element count I've
made it an integer because again like we
could be storing a lot of elements in
this case with a signed integer we could
be starting to million sorry two billion
so two billion is probably enough right
I don't think 64 32 thousand is um is
enough like yeah an integer is probably
a good choice here and if you always
need to have above two billion elements
it's probably very rare because that is
a lot of data you could always split it
up into multiple race okay so and then
we have the buy it so that that's it
we're just adding this field here
could I just extend field into array yes
of course I could but I'm not going to
all right so um set name we're gonna
steal yeah you guys can kinda see how
I'm going to end up reason card I might
make interfaces or I might make it a
general subclass called like container
and then that will have certain things
like set name and get bytes and stuff
because every name every container is
gonna have a name we're gonna talk about
actually laying this API out probably a
bit later I'm just going to implement it
right now and that will be fine so
perhaps that name will grab your bytes
again there's a-- going to be element
slightly differently this is going to be
exactly the same but this stuff again
let's just grab one on them right
so when we create this I really one
thing I really should do is make the
construction private right because the
only the only person are the only like
class really that's supposed to be
constructing field is field okay when we
call these static methods if we just
make a new field like that that really
shouldn't be a thing right that's not my
intention
all right all these are public so you
can always modify them before you
actually do pit get bites but
constructing a new field like that
doesn't really make sense most the time
unless you are going to overwrite
everything so starting off with the
default template which is basically what
this is is gonna be I think it's gonna
be the best all right so we've got this
so this is going to return an array I
should maybe prefix all these with stuff
like a C or a raincloud
all right because I I'm thinking that
this might be annoying if they start
conflicting with Java types I mean if we
start making cloth like I mean isn't it
isn't right actually a java type I bet
it is
it's Java reflect so suddenly a
reflection thing I was almost it's not
in adult Lang I think I'm safe right
sometimes we don't stop making stuff
like integer we'll be fine
okay so array array equals new array so
we're going to be taking in a name and
an array of something so let's start off
with our typical example integers we'll
call this just data yes because the
other ones were called value right yeah
so value and value versus data all right
so data so we'll erase that name type is
going to be integer
Dada is going to be int why is that
called int it's not rebuild integer from
now on I don't like to skimp out on some
names okay so we're going to write bytes
into a radar data and we're going to be
writing that in we haven't done that yet
all right fantastic it's time to do it
so this is gonna be fun so we could just
I guess we could choose the easiest way
or the simplest way in terms of writing
code for this would probably just better
called app so if we do something like
write bytes or pointer equals right
bytes in to destination pointer and
source I write again that is a lot of
function calls my ideally you probably
wouldn't do something like this unless
this was like an inline function but
it's okay well I mean like I keep
bringing these things up as I as I
implement the rest of these all I'll
have a little bit of a chat to you guys
as I keep bringing all of these things
up in terms of like performance and
stuff and I keep talking about
optimization you know like well I mean
we're using Java like there are some
things we could do in terms of
optimization but there's not a lot
honestly if this was C++ or C or
something like that we would be probably
spending more time thinking about how we
can make this faster but for now I've
got two things in mind hey I want to get
this totally implemented this could
totally be a generic function by the way
it has to be right
let's try write a generic function in
Java what how to even do that I actually
don't know
Java generics sorry it's been way too
long since I've done that um can I have
some examples please this is funny I
hope you guys don't mind that kind of
unprofessional thing about doing right
now I like to think this channel is a
human Channel
okay so it looks like you put the thing
here just before the return type that's
a bit weird
okay T all right so then that has to be
T see that's where it's gonna be it
unfortunate I'm not sure if we could you
not generalize this because there's no
real way to you just get the bias of any
type are they're not really yeah it's a
bit annoying isn't it because that now
needs to see if this was a template then
this wouldn't be a problem because it it
would just if like it wouldn't compile
if there was no right bytes that took in
one of the usages of T it's just that
here it has to actually be truly generic
not kind of like a template where it
actually doesn't really have to all
right
anyway if anyone knows in the comments
how to do this tell me and we'll rewrite
it as a generic thing but if there's no
elegant way to do it which I'm I suppose
there's not then I guess we'll just
we'll deal with all we have because the
thing that I'm thinking of is the fact
that like you know these are all
specializations of that generic type
that we can't implement if that was a T
thing we wouldn't know how many bite we
have to have any fights it took out what
we couldn't do either and we have to I'm
not sure anyway it would get complicated
really fast it just did actually all
right so we're almost done boolean value
this last one
this is relation stuff there seriously
all right done and the other thing I'm
changing is the type as well because
obviously it's going to as you can see
use the right right bytes
yeah all right done so we can now write
a raise so that's all we have to do now
and then we just return the Aram with
them so now we had a thousand of these
so we've got one for int short char
I'm sorry biochar bytes short char
bites short to make sure that we do it
oh this is important isn't it cuz it's
gonna be wrong so this has to be type
okay so now we probably okay this is
good I was gonna say there's something
missing here and there is we could
obviously just do something like I also
we don't even set in a County where we
need to set the count to be data billing
okay we could just kind of multiply this
with the rate account copy everything in
there like we did and everything will be
the best that's okay but again it is an
issue because it means that you actually
have to copy all the data now pretend
this is an array with a million elements
in it right copying every single one of
those million bytes into into into a
into another array right first of all
there's a huge waste of space I mean a
million vices are in there megabyte but
still that's a lot of just space to just
allocate and it's just it's just not a
list it's not even about the memory
usage it really isn't because a megabyte
I mean even though that is actually a
considerable amount of memory that still
isn't anything that we can't handle it's
the performance that comes with it right
allocating first of all that much
continuous memory or contiguous memory
is a chore but also there's copying
every single element like is it's it's
it's actually a problem it'll be a
measurable thing so what we want to do
instead is simply reference it how do
you reference it well glad you asked
actually really easy all we have to do
is just set a rate of data equals data
and not worry about the writing bytes so
actually becomes easier the issue is
that if that data gets garbage collected
for whatever reason this
reference dies right I don't think it
will get removed I'm trying to think
about it I think that I actually think
that in Java as long as it's as long as
the garbage collector says that we're
still holding on to that reference it
won't delete the memory or it went free
the memory so in fact this should work
again my my java is my lack of knowing
Java very well apparently he's coming
through again but um yeah as far as I
know I think the guy I don't think the
garbage collector really is allowed to
just say okay we're done again this
would be something that is a lot a lot
more problematic we got the data here
obviously that is something that would
be a lot more problematic if we were
actually using something like C++ and
then someone actually does delete the
data because of course it is in that
purpose it is in that like situation
possible to free memory that is still
being used somewhere and then we would
be really screwed because when we
actually write this data out then we
reach for it and it's not there okay
this is another thing that we have to
think about we've got this short array
of data that we really need to get that
into a byte array so
let's see if there's a way that we can
actually type so offer a bit of googling
this actually seems to be a problem
because no one as far as I can tell
actually has a good solution for this
looks like by Buffett rap might be
something that we can use there what
does that do
raps are by terrain to above that yeah
that's not only one alright so this is
not good so that doesn't seem to be a
way to do this every single thing that
I've read so far I spent about ten
minutes like it's been a while I have
suggested actually copying the data
which is unacceptable so here's what
we're gonna do we're actually going to
make we're actually going to make a
bunch of arrays
okay we're gonna make a short array so
short data we're gonna make you can you
guys kind of see where this is going
we're going to make one for each type
okay and then according to the type
we're going to set the appropriate array
and then according to of course which
type is set here we'll write that data
out now would I do this like his is
again it's not the best solution but it
looks like it's the only solution since
we actually can't get past Chavez type
system as far as I can tell right I
don't know everything about Java so I
can't tell you for sure if there's a
better way to do what I'm doing
obviously there would be I would be
doing it so feel free to use your
excellent Java knowledge to write a
better solution but I can't think of one
right now so we're gonna enter this is
gonna work fine like there's no there's
no issue with this this will perform
exactly the way we want it to the only
issue I like that kind of shape there
anyway the only issue with this is is it
looks a little bit messy but in terms of
like performance and how it's actually
gonna work it's gonna be beautiful
alright so and that that's all I really
care about
okay so in case you didn't catch on
instead of setting data here we actually
are going to set Shore starter all right
and then kind of so on and so forth
right so again we are setting references
that's not what we're doing we're not
copying data copying data would be
something like this okay this is
actually setting a reference so no
daughter is being copied
we're simply setting the pointer to this
data we're assigning that to this
pointer here again remember this is an
array so it is literally just a pointer
to a block of memory which contains this
actual D actual elements okay so it's
not like a bunch of elements here
they're not yeah this is just an this is
just an address that contains the actual
shorts okay all right awesome so we'll
continue this a child will do chá I
don't need to do that so this will be a
charred data let's just copy this
because I don't really want to
we as well all we really need to copy as
that oh that's it I make them all all
right sure in Stata so we still need
long float double and boolean so long
long-long float float float this is
lovely
what's wrong with you all right okay I
wish this one would come up is it anyway
cuz nah
oh we can change the names of all these
as well I've got I've been forgetting to
do that so this is double double double
and this is bullying whoops bullying
okay bully all right so let's change the
names quickly so this would be byte
that's actually the only correct one
sha sha in secure long loads we don't
really need to we could just I guess we
could just make create and then pass an
appropriate type of data but I kind of
just like I think when reading the code
it would be a lot easier to see this and
also it means you would make less
mistakes for example only less mistakes
but if you accidentally change the type
for example you really wouldn't know if
you did because there are so many
overloaded functions or if you do here
you wanna have to actually change your
code to reflect that again you might you
may you may or may not want that it's up
to you but I do I think I want to be
more specific with my types this is a
strongly typed language anyway so there
we go right that's that should be
everything let's test this out oh of
course
we forgot this so this is the actual
data that we're running out so that's
going to depend on the type so if the
type is did I did okay statement yeah
yeah I just realized that a veteran like
C++ style all right there we go
yeah that just came back to me alright
so if the type is set to lights then we
simply like it's been there's gonna be a
lot of this yeah
we simply do that all right otherwise if
type is set to I guess we'll begin with
the top which is like short if they are
really sorted by type I guess bullying
should be up they would buy it but
anyway
alright so short
Chah integer long float double bull in
and the other thing that changes of
course is that we write out short solder
instead of the other thing and Cha data
and in Stata and long data and flips
data and double daughter and bullying
daughter and that should be it alright
so let's test this out back in Maine
let's make an array I'm gonna solve with
bytes first array it's going to be close
data we're going to say 1 2 3 4 5 we're
going to have array array I guess we'll
have let's just import that now one I
guess we'll do get size as well here and
have that do we nope public and to get
size return 1 plus 2 plus named at
length glass
type hopes plus one plus one counters
for right yeah okay and then this is
gonna be difficult because getting that
size depends on what it actually is
which is fun
so public can't get array size or get
data size will pull it so in comes the
thing again this is the type of thing
that you could have avoided if Java was
either a a better language or if I was a
better Java programmer depending on
whether or not it's actually possible
anyway this is gonna be easy though so
this is gonna be return return in this
case yeah data dot length yes we'll do
times 1 or x type get size type to fight
let's copy and paste that a bunch of
times
and there
okay so again this as you can imagine
changes to short da-da-da-da-da and in
Tata and long data flawed data and
supple data this is yeah heaps of fun
this serialization series its actual
work is what it is no fun just work it's
still fun
I still enjoy this don't you worry
otherwise I wouldn't be doing it right
right okay sorry
there we have it um so now we can just
do plus get the other size will give us
the exact size in bytes so yes that's
good all right cool let's test it out so
ray ray array long bite of course call
it test will set the darts data
I mean we don't need to yeah so I'll
call this elements the data of course
will be arrayed I'll get size and then
we'll actually serialize this out so I
think I think I'll call this my stream
actually break it fights just because
that makes more sense and data I think
like if anything this should be called
data because actually the data that
we're doing so let's see what this does
if not crash okay cool
so that's a little bit on I think is it
alright let's go through this so type to
write or container type 2 which is array
then we've got a short which is the type
of data that's in there right no what is
it
Oh name like sorry for test then we've
got the type which is one which is a
bite that's correct then we've got the
count no we don't I was like the actual
oh wait obviously I'm still not printing
out anything so we've got name
we're gonna name a name then we got type
that we need to have count so we need to
print out counts this is why we test and
then we have called print out what we
need to do and then at the end we don't
print anything so really that should be
correct
I just don't understand what these are
all these four bytes at the end right
that's right that's because of course in
the size calculation I did include type
which is right here but I didn't
included in the by so that we wrote out
so now we should be good yeah this is
more like what I was expecting so then
here is that type sorry here's and
here's that count yes or not count type
sorry not count that's what I meant
count this variable sorry there it is
right here it's five which is correct
and then here are the five elements
those are let's try something a bit
harder let's do an int array and not
like part of it you know different into
Ray so nothing really should change here
I'll run it this again it becomes a lot
larger there so I guess we'll kind of
steal it I guess we will I'm gonna step
up sublime text this might be easier
with sublime text guys taking a while
tarpon alright it's open oh good oh good
note sorry here's the data let's see if
we can find the beginning of it what we
saw with one so I guess that's the
beginning of data and then we'll cut in
here as well okay so to then we have the
name length we got the name we've got
the type which is four which is correct
integer then we've got a bunch of zeros
so what's that all about
that's data is it no that's count right
so count is zero okay that's wrong
and then we've got the five things so
that's of course also wrong because I
must be printing data yeah
okay some I'm super like the my count
wait hang on a minute
so counters honor I'm I don't say that
oh I forgot to set that I was gonna say
yeah all right fair enough I forgot to
set that all right third time lucky
first I forgot the actual count variable
to write it out I'm always neglecting
count here I guess that's because it's
the only aviation above field all right
updated version so really the only
things that should be updated is this
section here just become that sorry
there we go five elements and here they
are let's try something a bit more fun
just to see if this can handle it in
data equals new int 50,000 for int I
equals 0 I is less than data dot length
like was plus will make a static random
random new random and we'll put that and
we'll say random dot next int no bounds
gotta I equals that and we'll just do
that all right should we printed the
console or let's just do it
wow I printed very fast
I'm not still printing yeah I was gonna
say that all right no that did print
fast ok still going now and now it's
done it's a lot of data
Wow ok so there's all the data I mean
didn't crash so I'm gonna assume it
worked
uh-hum ok cool so there we go that's
gonna wrap up this thing I hope you guys
enjoyed this video of the series Asian
series next time I think it's gonna be
episode 10 so one of the first things
that I really want to do is actually
make it so that we can write this out to
a file as binary so that we can view it
in like a hex editor and make sure that
everything is ok there because obviously
if we do something something like print
50,000 things it's going to be a bit
annoying but also we're going to start
taking a look at the most complicated
container type and that is an object so
an object is just a collection of
multiple arrays and fields and objects
also have names all right cool thanks
watching guys hope you enjoyed if you
did and you want to see more videos like
this then please support me on patreon
if you can and all want to you get
certain rewards like access to these
kind of super secret sparkly repository
as well as all the gerotor incurred by
github for just 5 bucks a month which is
a very good deal if I didn't have that
card and I would definitely pay that
much money to be honest because I think
it's it's pretty cool code but that just
helps me make more videos and I'm that's
what I'm really trying to do this year
which is why I'm making all these suresh
videos so anyway if you can't support me
on patreon then that's totally ok just
hit the like button and keep watching my
videos I'll see you guys next time
goodbye